djd nice my buddy is here with us
tonight taking a little break from club
quarantine today you started DJing on
Instagram when we all kind of started
yourself isolation just for you and your
friends and it just grew into this whole
community and you had over a hundred
thousand people rocking Baku together
yes I think actually on Sunday when I
was saying it was a hundred fifty
thousand if you're not mistaken it was
great you know it started here in uh in
my kitchen you know I was sitting back
and just wanting to I was actually
missing my friends and I wanted to play
music you know I mean we know each other
it's like I'm so used to either being
around my kids almost behind turntables
and seeing people and you know the whole
self-isolation thing was driving me nuts
like I need to play music and I need to
feel some energy so I decided to go into
my ig live and play music and all of a
sudden my friends came anything there's
only 200 of us and then the next day it
was 2001 after it was like 15,000 and
then this Friday was like all of a
sudden JLo was in there and Drake popped
in and you know the anumber is increased
in but then Saturday was like everything
you had Michelle Obama
you had Oprah your girl you know Joe
Biden Bernie you know Janet Jackson
hanging out you know
Lionel Richie it was insane like it was
the same because people I know it was
that everyone was looking for something
cool to do and initially you know when
we started we were all just kind of like
having fun like hey what's that Michelle
I'll meet you at the bar my tab is open
and it really just turned into like this
fun group of people like just like going
there to entertain each other while I
was playing use
and people found it and they grew it's
great well I don't know if you felt this
but you know I know you said you were at
home by yourself I'm here I'm single I'm
by myself and so this time can get very
um isolated you know what I'm saying it
can start to get very lonely and that
can sit with you and so what I found in
Club quarantine and you just playing
your music and kind of giving us a piece
of yourself it was a community I didn't
feel so alone for a time I felt like
that I had someone here with me that I
could laugh with people I could talk to
people because it wasn't only just you
playing your music and became this chat
room of everybody I felt like I was
party it was great and that that's part
of the experience it was people
communicating we were interacting with
each other you know so you know you said
during this time I was feeling like you
know like my my situation was unique you
know I wouldn't imagine that you were
sitting on the hall as well and that
this is what made us it made us happy it
made us connect and you know as a shared
experience and you know this is probably
one of the most memorable moments of my
life yeah I saw when Michelle Obama
stepped into the room you froze a little
bit and I'm screaming at the phone you
played the White House what are you
doing you know what you know what it was
it was um usually when I played for her
for the Obamas I'm in their world you
know so I prepared there for them in
their world she was in my world like
that was a notice MySpace so I created
that space for some friends and then she
popped in oh and I wanted it to feel
comfortable for her and at the same time
the song was ending but I was like wait
what what am i planned what am I talking
about like I beat for her she loves
beyoncé yes then I get my groove but it
was I you know I was definitely stripped
for a minute because I didn't expect it
to happen I wanted it to happen I kind
of asked for it to happen
wasn't sure if it would but when it did
it was like wow you know what this is
something cool that
we have going on and it made you know my
reason for wanting wanting her to stop
by was because there are people that
were feeling a little down you know and
this this room was kind of like
uplifting everyone's spirits and it was
like there was a person in there on
Friday that was like wow Jana was here
Drake was here in Kelly Rowland man Dean
I says everyone
the only person missing is Michelle
Obama so I figured if I if I could you
know if I can try to like magic to make
it happen like you know I think what
happened the fact that it did was just
awesome
well your spirit is just awesome too and
I just wonder how you have been doing
how you have been holding up because
you've been providing such a service to
all of us but I know you're a daddy and
I know your girls aren't with you and so
have you been holding up during this
time I mean it's been hard but the the
what made it is a lot easier is being
able to converse with you guys like in
in this room but like a lot of you are
my friends you know I mean not a hundred
and fifty thousand people what that core
group of 200 or we're all friends we've
all known each other for years and like
that made me feel you know at ease you
know and uh I mean it's a very difficult
time for all of us you know yeah
especially when when you're away from
your loved ones and the fact that
technology has allowed us to feel a
little bit closer and now with what we
what we accomplished the other day now
we could actually dance together like
people like America Ferrera then sent
you like you know posted a video it's a
grenade
which she was like just spinning
standing around with a phone and just
dancing and it was great to know like
what exactly what I was imagining like
the while I was playing I was just
imagining these people dancing yeah I
posted my video too I was trying to do
my best new edition that's okay because
I'm gonna be cute at the club the next
time I'm gonna marry now during your set
sometimes I would hear the doorbell ring
and you would go away and then you come
back and it was like people celebrities
were sending you things like sending you
bottles of wine I saw will
sent you a bunch of just water like what
is that like when the doorbell rings
like hey
Will Smith wanted you to have this well
it was a little creepy at first because
I'm like why will is that powerful that
he can just get my address
so okay we're Wilson you know Will and
Jada sent water and you know Chris
Spencer sent why
it's Dale sent wine and like some of my
other friends were sending food and it
was this is beautiful like people wanted
to make sure you know since I was
providing entertainment they thought it
was just about you know I was providing
entertainment for there but what they
were doing for me speaking my soul by
just being there and just you know it
can get lonely I'm not a big you know I
don't watch television all day I'm not
that guy listen to music at home I'm a
big talk radio guy and after a while
sitting in this department I feel like I
watch everything on television I've seen
all the reruns I've seen every episode
of blue yeah but oh I'm over it I need
to play some music now one crazy
we can look Bloods I was I knew Donnie
Wahlberg was 14 and I was listening to
him and Jenny chat on her of her show DJ
McCarthy show on Sirius XM and he said
that they invited you to come on the new
kids cruise with them and you're gonna
do it are you gonna go on and hang with
the new kids I mean with this country to
do it you know like I'm there like I
love done yeah see how we bump I was
always a fan you know growing up
obviously that was like my generation in
music but Jenny asked me to be the
surprised DJ at his 50th he actually
knew my daughter and I will both of my
kids and I out to UM how to to Chicago
and and it was a great experience you
know like I thought like I actually
learned to like really really love
Donnie I can communicate all the time
but when I first you know started
rocking night you know I'm doing one of
the new kids song he's like no I'm cool
like I want to hear what you would
played what I tried to tell him you know
I play every kid and we just had a blast
and we became friends after that and you
know I love them they're they're awesome
people and you see like they're always
in Club
yeah screaming like we want to get to 20
we need to get to 30 there and we
appreciate the shout out for
entertainment tonight as well we
appreciate you having us out I don't
want to give just a little bit about
YouTube and about your background
because you're not new to this you've
been in the game you're a celebrity
yourself you were you know um you you're
a rapper and you ran for so I don't even
like to say back in Big Jim part of
Boogie Down Productions Kara's one screw
on one of my favorite records of all
time self-destruction
you also had a huge hit and call me D
nice what made you decide to start
playing music I know you'd love to what
made you decide to say hey I'm gonna be
a DJ so I left the music industry for
years almost a decade like you know away
and you know I was missing that vibe
that whole you know the fellowship I had
with other artists and one day q-tip
invited q-tip from A Tribe Called Quest
was spinning with Mark Ronson and they
invited me it's got to be like around
2004 in 2003 2004 they had a party in
New York City pretty popular party then
went to in and hung out with him and I
couldn't believe that you could play
classic beats like that with like I mean
the room was small but they were playing
these classic records but everyone was
happy
and I was like man I want to do that
like I want to play that and they mean
they were playing like James Brown
they were I mean it was just funky like
come on you know and I was like man
listen this is what I love but I also
love jay-z so you know I just figured
out how I wanted to combine my style
like I love I love playing everything
but I didn't want to just play classics
I love some new records you know like I
love the new Drake record I love the new
you know ho
you know any anything that Rihanna puts
out it's just always in my playlist you
know so it's just great to like find a
way to just like bridges the gap between
old and new with just through music so
that's great now I'm you you've
definitely done that a couple things
here
your style is sweating my man and
whenever you've got this thing going not
with all of this color this is like this
is would you do something where you have
hat changes and it became such a fun
game throughout your set people were
taking shots
oh excuse me one second I'm sorry as you
were saying as you were saying people
were just looking at me and I was
looking at myself I'm like man I'm
talking looking at myself on the screen
I mean just put something else put
another hat on it was asking followed
and then it became a thing now so like
now I think I'm gonna travel with like
four five paths it's kind of switch it
up every now home in but no is this fun
it was fun barcaro chat you know it was
great I know you said you were feeling
um your you were feeling a little like
rundown are you gonna still do this
every night or are you gonna pick
certain nights are you gonna keep it to
the weekend cuz nobody knows how long
this self-isolation is gonna last I
think I'm probably just gonna do do it
once once once a week because I was
tired I mean I was planning so long like
marathon sets like nine hours and enough
we returned the next day and especially
like it was a bit much after uh after
that night the Saturday night when it
was crazy
easy like that Sunday morning forget
about it my phone was just ringing off
the hook at like 3000 text message gives
every agent every agent calling you know
everyone's trying to be a publicist and
it was it was over in no star was reborn
yeah I've been here a long time
no no I don't I'm very I'm very grateful
and humble that people you know after
all these years are still like
appreciative of what I'm doing and what
I'm able to bring to the table through
music you know like there could be worse
things to do but I found my way doing
something that I actually have you I
know you said people have been calling I
know because I've seen you everywhere
you know on morning shows I've heard
Oprah talking about you yesterday and
how that kind of lifted her and some
things she you know wanted to sit down
with you have you had has this really
opened doors for you that you never even
thought about so you you know being in
the music industry as long as I have
when I was a recording artist yes I did
a lot of media growing up you know we
sold millions of records and but it was
a different time in the hip-hop culture
as a DJ this was the first time that I
was even though I played major events so
you know Super Bowl against Oscar those
events were always about the event
itself it wasn't about me like you could
have like put it me you can put any
other DJ there even though our styles
are not the same but anyone could have
been standing behind the turntables what
this has done for me and just because of
the love of music and the love of like
wanting to give and share with people it
opened up so many doors you know like
comminity I DJ for Oprah twice and she
didn't remember she was like wait you
were the same person
[Laughter]
[Laughter]
I actually know make help tell so and
Gayle is always like she was always nice
and always sweet but Gayle was really
she was genuinely happy when that night
was like going the way it was like she
you know immediately hit me up like this
is great like I'm really happy for you
and but Dad so I this is definitely
opened up a lot of doors and it's gonna
be interesting to see where where this
goes because I mean now when I was
younger it was
coming from a place of eagle and young
and wanted to be hot none of that
matters now I'm in a place of wanting to
serve morning - good things wanted to
help provide better opportunities for
people so I think this is like this is
gonna turn to something really good
[Music]